j'ai toujours eu envie au fond de faire
une la chanson ou être comédienne de
quelque chose du genre
renée claude c'est une voix un sourire
une élégance unique
[Musique]
la montréalaise étudie le chant le piano
et le théâtre et cela nourrit son
interprétation des textes noté stéphane
venne lui à l'écrire à plusieurs dans
cette chanson symbole d'une époque de
bouleversements
l'éternel a provoqué en même temps c'est
ça que font les artistes lui arthur
reflète des changes mais où je suis
provoque des choses
cette grande interprète à la voix unique
était une femme éprise de liberté
oui on y c'était une lune une femme
éprise de liberté effectivement qui
voulait vivre sa vie sa vie d'artiste sa
vie de femme et qui ne s'est pas gêné
pour la vivent à 100 milles à l'heure
[Musique]
les succès continuent de s'enchaîner
dans les années 70 quand elle travaille
avec lucas montant rien ne résiste à la
sensibilité et à l'audace de
l'interprète quand on y arrive elle
avait un côté très très contemporain
d'autres chantaient convient non l
arrivée des cadets bon je suis très très
contente en être l actuel elle sera de
plusieurs grands événements comme la
saint-jean de 1975
rapport ci
dans les années 80 elle montre son sens
de l'humour dans un spectacle hommage à
clémence desrochers qui reprendra la
fiche plusieurs fois au fil des ans
c'était une fille tellement sérieuse et
tellement exigeante et qui faisaient de
travail est tellement fort pour pour
rendre justice sur aucun et atteint même
succès éclatant durable et
internationale pour son spectacle sur le
chansonnier français georges brassens
qu'elle aime depuis toujours
en 1993 elle plonge plus loin dans les
chansons à texte avec celle du français
léo ferré et dont le pont et c'est
encore le succès critique et populaire
lorsqu'elle monte sur les planches de
l'opéra montréal pour son rôle dans les
ligues ans
en 2019 le grand public apprend qu'elle
souffre depuis longtemps de la maladie
d'alzheimer
[Musique]
depuis les hommages se sont multipliés
pour célébrer cette grande interprète
qui a su magnifier la langue d'ici
[Musique]
si nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal